Гроші з весілля подружжя Войтенків вирішило не витрачати, а вкласти в нове житло
Їхня однокімнатна квартира - на 12 поверсі цього ще недобудованого житлового комплексу.
Будівельну компанію порадили знайомі.
Кажуть, за 30 років на ринку вона не мала жодного довгобуду.
Та найголовніше - вимагає мінімальний пакет документів.
Паспорт і код. Це все. Ніяких не потрібно було справок про доходи, забудовник тобі довіряє.
І навіть кредитну історію не дивиться.
Є можливість у забудовника свої ризики чимось перекривати.
Для забудовника це, я вважаю, що ризиковано, бо зараз люди не надійні. А для нас великий плюс.
Умови забудовника наступні: перший внесок - 30% від вартості житла, а далі три роки розстрочки.
Для Войтенків це щомісяця по 15 тисяч гривень, тобто майже половина сімейного бюджету.
Це найкращі умови, які вони змогли знайти в Україні.
У нас спочатку теж був варіант з кредитом у банку. Ми ходили консультуватись.
Але там дуже великий відсоток одразу нараховують.
І ми навіть не намагались зібрати ці документи, не було сенсу.
Бо майже другу квартиру можна купити за ті відсотки, які вони нараховують за ці 10 років.
Нині на ринку нерухомості бракує чітких правил, які б регулювали інвестиції в житло.
Забудовник диктує свої умови,
банки - свої, а українці на свій страх і ризик обирають прийнятні для них.
В ідеалі, захищати права і тих, і інших мав би єдиний інструмент.
В Україні він навіть існує - це Фонд інвестування будівництва.
Його створили ще у 2005 році після внесення зміни в Закон України "Про інвестиційну діяльність".
Втім, за словами самих учасників ринку, Фонд свої функції не виконує
і через високі податки не є популярним.
До прикладу, я приведу інвестування на ринку Польщі.
У них існує одна єдина схема - через так звані рахунки повернічі.
Аналог до нашого Фонду фінансування.
Це єдиний визнаний механізм, який дозволяє контролювати як і саму забудову,
забудовника, захищати інвестиції і контролювати, чи ці інвестиції відправлені саме на будівництво,
а не на щось інше.
І такі засоби контролю здійснює як держава, так і банк.
Орися Юзвишин розповідає, що нині Польща є лідером за обсягами іпотечного будівництва
і змагається з такими країнами як Німеччина та Англія.
Ставка на іпотеку там максимум 3% річних. Тоді як в Україні цей же банк надає іпотечний кредит під 14%.
Аби в Україні була дешева іпотека, має запрацювати цілий комплекс заходів, пояснює фінансистка.
Зокрема, Національний банк має знизити регуляторні обмеження.
Що я маю на увазі… Іпотека на 20 років, а беремо ми депозити максимум на 12 місяців.
Відповідно, ми повинні правильно і вміло користуватись цими грошима.
І нас Національний банк заставляє формувати великі резерви,
і ці резерви - це додаткові кошти, які перекладаються на вартість іпотеки.
Якщо Нацбанк буде зменшувати свої вимоги до резервів,
відповідно, ми зможемо здешевляти вартість іпотечного кредиту.
Рівень іпотечного кредитування в Україні дуже низький.
Так, 2019 року державний "Ощадбанк" видав трохи більше тисячі кредитів на житло.
На первинному ринку, при першому внескові 30%, він надає кредит строком до 20 років
під майже 16% річних.
У інших банках кількість виданих іпотечних кредитів ще менша.
Проблема також і в тому, що далеко не всі українці мають "білі", тобто офіційні зарплати,
а тому не можуть пройти фінансовий моніторинг та підтвердити свою платоспроможність.
Cеред змін, які варто запровадити - розрахунок відповідно до сімейного доходу,
а не однієї людини, вважає Олексій Білоконь, керівник групи компаній-забудовників.
Я Вам скажу відверто, запит на іпотеку я розцінюю у форматі 20-30% від усіх запитів до відділу продажів.
Це високий відсоток, але ті, хто беруть іпотеку - 2-3% зі ста. Зараз поясню чому.
Завищені вимоги до кінцевого споживача - треба довести походження доходів.
Ми всі добре розуміємо, що далеко не у всіх білі заробітні плати…
Ми все одно всі обмежені можливостями кінцевого споживача
і наявність доступної іпотеки - однозначно драйвер розвитку економіки.
Як для будівельного ринку, так і споживчого.
Нині власне житло потребують 6 мільйонів українців,
а ще 20 мільйонів живуть в перенаселених квартирах.
За підрахунками аналітиків, якщо темпи будівництва залишатимуться на такому ж рівні,
як тепер, то Україні треба понад 160 років,
аби наздогнати європейські країни за показниками забезпечення житлом.
Якщо ми зробимо дешеву іпотеку, хоча б на 8-10%,
це відразу збільшить продажі та об'єм будівництва на 30-40%.
Це мінімум триста тисяч людей отримують нове якісне житло,
це сто тисяч квартир і додатково двісті тисяч робочих місць з'явиться в будівельній галузі.
Цей той локомотив, який може підняти економіку.
Про амбітні для України 10% іпотеки вже восени 2020 року
говорив експрем'єр-міністр України Олексій Гончарук.
Для його уряду дешева іпотека - була ключовим пунктом для запуску економіки.
Програму кредитування Гончарук мав представити на Першому іпотечному форумі,
втім, саме в цей день Верховна Рада його звільнила.
А прогнозувати, чи залишиться дешева іпотека у фокусі уваги нового Кабміну,
особливо на тлі пандемії коронавірусу, вельми сумнівно.
Тим часом Войтенки, аби мінімізувати витрати, переїхали до батьків.
Під одним дахом тут нині живе три родини.
Молоде подружжя розраховує, що забудовнику вдасться виконати свої обіцянки
і вже через рік вони зможуть святкувати новосілля.